-We're a week into
the Biden administration,
and Republicans
have made it clear
they will do everything possible
to sabotage
the Democrats' agenda,
while moving quickly to quash
the upcoming impeachment trial
of former
President Donald Trump.
For more on this,
it's time for a Closer Look.
♪♪
The modern Republican Party
has no discernible
policies or principles
other than feigned persecution
and cultural grievances.
Seriously, what is
even one policy
they've advanced to help
working people?
"Well, we gave your CEO
a tax cut,
so maybe he'll look more relaxed
in the preflight video."
There are very real,
unprecedented existential crises
swirling around us
on a daily basis,
creating suffering and misery
for millions of Americans.
And instead,
the right is obsessed
with trivial garbage like this.
-Right around the election,
I had one million followers
on Twitter.
Now I have under 900,000.
Really, I mean, literally
in a couple of weeks.
I don't know
what's going on there.
-Oh, I'm sorry.
I was just lighting a prayer
candle for Maria Bartiromo.
That was a truly
harrowing story, Maria.
When people talk about
what we've lost this past year,
I think first on that list
is going to be
your Twitter followers.
Thank you for speaking out
about this.
You're like a modern-day
Erin Brockovich
or Sully Sullenberger.
I hope you get your own biopic.
Thousands of people
have been dying a day
in overwhelmed hospitals.
Millions are out of work,
losing their health insurance
and falling into poverty,
and child hunger is on the rise.
Republicans
and people like Bartiromo
have powerful platforms
with millions of viewers.
They could spend
any amount of time they want
talking about any of that.
Instead, they manufacture
dumb grievances
to distract from real problems
and make themselves
feel like victims.
It's their entire
business model.
And after Joe Biden got elected,
they amped it up
to an absurd degree.
-Curt Schilling wrote
a social media post
defending Donald Trump,
and in 2021, that's not allowed.
You could lose
your insurance for that.
You could also lose
your bank account, your website,
your access to email
and social media,
your ability to communicate
with the outside world,
and there's nothing
you can do about it,
because you can also
lose your lawyer.
No legal representation for you.
How long before they cut off
your water and electricity?
Before UPS
won't deliver your packages?
And not to wreck your day,
but guess what?
Amazon is now one of America's
biggest grocery providers.
Good thing you don't
need to eat.
Once politicians attempt
to control what you believe,
they are no longer politicians.
They are, by definition,
dictators.
And if they succeed in
controlling what you believe,
you are no longer a citizen.
You are not a free man.
You are a slave.
-If they control
what you believe
you're no longer a citizen.
If they tell you what to think,
you're no longer free.
And when they tell you
you have to wear
not just a shirt and shoes,
but pants
to California Pizza Kitchen,
you're a slave.
And how long before they cut off
your water, your electricity?
How long before
they tow your car
for parking on the sidewalk
outside Chuck E. Cheese?
Not because you were drunk,
mind you,
but because you were in a hurry
and you were drunk.
And when you hide
from the police in the ball pit,
don't be surprised
when they find you,
because those ball pits are
shallower than they look,
and as an adult man,
part of you will be
sticking out and visible.
How long before that happens?
I'll tell you how long.
It happened to me yesterday.
And then this week,
there was yet another,
even more ridiculous example
of this feigned victimhood
when the MyPillow guy famous
for inventing a worse version
of a thing we've had
for 500 years...
[ As Mike Lindell ]
"Honey, I've got an idea.
What about, like, a soft thing
for your head at night?"
"You mean a pillow, honey?"
"Yeah. I'm heading to the lab."
"Don't rush back."
Famous for inventing a pillow,
and for spreading
the deranged conspiracy theory
that China used voting machines
to hack the election,
went on Fox News to complain
about his products
getting dropped from stores.
-For the crime of having
different opinions.
Mike Lindell has just been
banned from Twitter.
Several retailers have also
stopped selling his products.
That happened today.
That would include
Bed, Bath and Beyond,
Kohl's and Kroger.
That list is bigger.
There's also HEB,
the Shopping Channel, ShopHQ.
I mean, they just keep
turning in their POs
and saying, "We don't want
MyPillow anymore."
-Dear God, Kroger
and the Shopping Channel
stopped selling MyPillow?
Whither freedom?
If George Washington heard this,
he would roll over in his grave,
which is still more comfortable
than rolling on to MyPillow.
People don't know this,
but that's actually what
caused the Revolution.
The British told Thomas Paine
he couldn't sell his line
of toilet seat cushions
in the town square anymore
because his opinions
were too controversial,
so Thomas Paine started
the Revolutionary War.
Thomas Paine's
toilet seat cushions.
Time to drain the main vein?
Do it on a Paine?
Paine's toilet seat cushions.
It's just common sense.
That was a joke for
my 8th-grade history teacher.
Shout out to, um...
I cannot remember.
Well, I guess that's why
he or she always told me
I was so bad at history.
I just see a blur.
They were definitely
by a chalkboard.
Also, I should say,
I'm skeptical of big tech, too.
So we're lots of progressives.
Don't get me wrong,
I love having Donald Trump
off Twitter,
not to mention
all the other toxic racists
and conspiracy theories
that have been booted off.
But my concern is that
these companies are monopolies,
which is why I think
we should follow the lead
of Elizabeth Warren
and Bernie Sanders
and break them up.
Just because you agree
with Jack Dorsey on some things
doesn't mean you will agree
on the next thing.
And if you don't believe me,
may I present Exhibit Beard?
But as for stores not wanting
to carry your product,
you lied and said
the election was rigged
and tried to get the president
to overturn it.
You can't be the public face
of your company
and the public face of an
attempt to overthrow democracy
and not expect there
to be some fallout.
You could have named your
company
"SleepWell" or
"Gravel in a Sack"
and stayed in the shadows,
but no, had to be "MyPillow."
And you had to call yourself
"the MyPillow guy"
and be in all the commercials
like some knock-off Tom Selleck.
Well, listen up.
It takes more than a mustache
to be a spokesman, buddy.
You need that Selleck charm.
By the way, I got one of those
reverse mortgages
he told me about.
And in the end,
he did take my house,
But he was an absolute gentleman
about it.
A true blue one!
[ Laughter ]
This is all they have --
whining and obstruction,
imagined grievances,
paranoia
and conspiracy theories.
Even Donald Trump,
the former president
who spent two months
deeply engaged
in a concerted effort
to overthrow democracy
and install himself
as an unelected dictator
who incited a violent
insurrection of seditionists,
who ransacked the Capitol,
is in their minds, a victim.
-I don't even think there's
a basis for impeachment.
Now they're going to turn around
and bring about impeachment.
Yet they say they're for unity.
I mean, they beat him up
before he got into office.
They're beating him up
after he leaves office.
I mean, at some point,
I mean, give the man a break.
-At some point?
It's been three weeks.
Give the man a break?
At some point later
in the same month?
But, yes, please,
for once in his life,
give poor Donald Trump a break.
This poor man, who,
despite having bone spurs,
pulled himself up
by his bootstraps.
You know how much
bone spurs hurt
when you're pulling on boots
with straps?
This man worked his way up,
worked his way up
from hardscrabble roots,
using just his hands,
cashed a million dollar
check from his father,
toiled long days
in a dark casino
and long nights inhaling
wind song and glitter
at Studio 54.
He made it in business
the hard way
by bravely cheating on his taxes
and refusing to pay
his contractors.
And worst of all, he has
to drive his own golf cart.
I mean, look at that poor man,
so exhausted he's about
to fall over.
Seriously,
all Trump, his entire life,
all he's had are breaks.
He's famously
the dumbest man alive.
He has no discernible talents
or skills.
If Trump weren't born rich,
he'd be the old guy
working at the bowling alley
who gets busted
for huffing shoe spray.
[ Imitates spraying ]
"This here kills COVID."
"I just got an idea.
What if we put
something comfortable
on top of the box spring?"
"A mattress?"
"Yeah, the MyMattress."
Hello, patent office?
It's me again.
No, I'm not calling
about pencils this time.
It's a new idea."
Also, the last point
I'll make, Nikki Haley,
maybe instead of
asking Democrats
to give Trump a break,
you should ask yourselves
why you, the Republican Party,
gave him so many.
For four years,
you excuse his behavior.
So, of course, he kept
pushing it.
You're like a rich parent,
asking the court for mercy
for their bratty teen,
saying,
"Please, Your Honor,
give him a break.
It's what I always did.
Every time he stole or lied
or cheated on a test,
I looked him in the eye and
said, 'You're my special boy,
and nothing you do will ever
change how much I love you.'
And yet he kept stealing
and lying and cheating.
And I kept forgiving him,
sometimes even helped him.
I believe the legal term
is aiding and abetting.
And now he's accused
of hijacking a bus
full of senior citizens
and taking their pills
and then forcing the seniors
to rout liquor stores for them
to get their pills back,
something I know
for a fact he did,
because it's long
been his dream.
Well, all I can say to you,
Your Honor, is give him a break.
It's got to work
one of these days."
It's hard at this point
to reach any conclusion
other than
that the Republican Party
is fine with what Trump did
and they'd be fine with it
if he did it again or even
if he did something worse.
It's a party that is radicalized
against democracy
in favor of authoritarianism.
There is nothing, nothing Trump
could do to antagonize them,
not because they're cowards,
although they are,
but because
they agree with them.
At a certain point, we just have
to take them at their word.
If you sit down to dinner
with some friends
and one of them says, "You know
what's delicious?
Human flesh,"
you might think it's a joke.
But when you go
to their apartment
and they're sautéing
a human hand,
you have to ask yourself,
"Is Gary a cannibal?"
And then, by the way,
if you stay for dinner,
you're a cannibal, too,
even if you have salad
the next day.
45 Senate Republicans
voted Tuesday
to dismiss
Trump's impeachment trial.
At some point,
you just have to accept
that the reason they don't want
to convict Trump
for inciting an insurrection
to overthrow a democracy
is they don't care
that he incited an insurrection
to overthrow democracy
and they wouldn't care
if he tried it again.
Instead, they're once again
framing Trump as the victim
and casting the Democrats calls
for accountability
as a demand for vengeance.
-This impeachment is nothing
more than a partisan exercise
designed to further divide
the country.
Democrats claim to want
to unify the country,
but impeaching
a former president,
a private citizen,
is the antithesis of unity.
-It's vindictive.
This is all about
the left's demands for revenge.
-They hate Donald J. Trump,
and they're engaging in an act
that I think is petty.
I think it is retribution.
I think it is vindictive.
And I think it's
a waste of time.
And so, to coin a phrase,
I think it's time to move on.
-Man, Ted Cruz,
you really have no shame.
Also, first of all, shave, dude.
You look like the Unabomber
at a custody hearing.
Second, of course,
you want to move on.
You did this even after the mob
stormed the Capitol
to overturn the election.
You still voted
You're like a guy
who robs a bank,
and then even after it
all goes south,
you still get caught and use
the money to buy a Porsche.
"I want to feel the wind
and my scraggly beard."
Also, please stop with this
preposterous talking point
that impeachment
is somehow divisive.
You know, it's much more
divisive than impeachment?
Trying to throw out the votes
of 81 million Americans,
then inciting a mob
to violently storm the Capitol
the overthrow democracy.
Would you say that's more or
less unifying than impeachment?
Just be honest and say
you're fine with what Trump did
and you'd be fine with him
doing it again.
It would be heinous and evil,
but it would at least
make this whole debate
much easier.
Then we wouldn't have to listen
to your [bleep] excuses anymore.
I mean, you know what you are.
We know what you are.
Who are we pretending for?
The kids?
One of our two main political
parties is fully radicalized
against democracy
in favor of authoritarianism.
It's a movement
of powerful interests
backed by wealthy
corporate patrons,
fueled by imagined grievances
and conspiracy theories.
We can't ignore it.
We can't look away from it.
We can't just shrug
our shoulders and say...
-I don't know
what's going on there.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women and children
living with HIV AIDS,
cancer and other
serious illnesses,
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the donate button.
Stay safe, wash your hands,
wear a mask.
We love you.